I am live
but I don't see it on
it's my life showing okay
technology at its best hello everyone
and welcome to number six part 6 the
final installment of start with why good
to see you
we are broadcasting live on YouTube and
for the first time on Facebook so hello
youtube hello Facebook nice to see
everybody thanks for coming back
it is our final installment but let us
recall the words of dr. Seuss he said
don't cry because it's over smile
because it happened
this has been a joy for me as well I've
been looking forward to these every week
let's see we're gonna make this last one
a little bit special here's the reason
we decided to do these start with why is
10 years old and my publisher and I
thought wouldn't be a good idea to
update it bring it into the modern day
and do a 10-year anniversary edition
then I thought well why should I read
the book by myself I should invite other
people to to read with me and so we
decided to do book club and the whole
idea of book club was not about reading
a book it was about doing something
together especially in these kovat times
we thought it would be really fun to do
something where we wanted people to
organize into book clubs just have a
reason have an excuse to do something
together and get on the get on the phone
to talk to each other so that's why
we're doing this so thank you for
joining me if you want to tune back to
any of the previous book clubs sections
one through five
we keep them up on YouTube they're there
all the time please go and check them
out or share any pieces that you'd like
with anybody else today we're going to
be discussing part six discovery
discover it what is it what to call it
was gold I have it right here
it was Oh discover why thank you and
it's all about the origins you know this
was a nice short little section thank
goodness this is these past six weeks
were the quickest I've ever reread a
book but it was a nice short little
section but what I liked about it was it
really showed that why is deeply inside
of us every single one of us has a why
it's our it's our God
given right to have a why and our wine
never changes through our whole lives
because it is fundamentally an origin
story we are all the sum totals of how
we were raised the experiences we had
when we were young the lessons we
learned made us who we are and it's the
same for organizations a why of an
organization is fundamentally it's an
origin story there's a reason why an
organization was founded and it's when
it's founded with a why that's where
passion can live when it's founded by
some financial thing because somebody
read an article about some business
opportunity nobody's passionate about
those things it's hard to produce
passion when that when there wasn't a
why to start it in the first place it's
just a functional structure just a bunch
of transactions that's why those
businesses tend to be uninspiring and
they don't last very long either and you
you read one of my favorite stories
which is the story of Ben Coleman I saw
I seen a documentary on ESPN about Ben
komen and that's when I decided to write
about it and and I reached out to Ben to
talk to him and he's such a lovely kid
and it was really this just incredible
story of how when we compete against
others nobody wants to help us but when
we compete against ourselves everyone
wants to help us and I think this goes
so-so to the pureness of what it means
to start with why which is really it's a
personal adventure and I talked about in
my later book the infinite game that
this adventure that we run is infinite
and the goal is to leave something
behind our companies our families you
know having children is about passing on
your values to someone else so that they
may continue to carry them forward long
be long beyond our own years same thing
with a well built organization with a
strong foundation that's what why and
how is it's a strong foundation of
belief and cause and values and the
whole idea is that we're building our
organizations we're living our lives so
that they may continue on without us so
that we can literally live on forever
and this is the beauty of starting with
why and so when we show up to compete
against others then others compete
against us and
a game of undermining each other it's a
recipe to have an organization end in
our lifetimes and as Ben komen proves
that when we show up for ourselves that
we don't have to be the fastest runner
we don't have to be the strongest runner
we just have to keep going and we we do
it to prove to ourselves that that we
that we believe in something bigger than
ourselves it's amazing how many people
rush in to help now that's my own
personal story remember this book came
about as a personal experience I wrote
about it in here and by the way I
purposely put it at the end the
publisher wanted me to put it at the
beginning of the book the I am a failure
they wanted me to put it right as the
introduction of the of the of the book
and I remember that was the first
disagreement I had with my publisher I
said I absolutely refused because the
book wasn't about me and so I put it as
far away the people who never finished
the book who would never get to it the
story of how I had to come to terms with
the fact that I was a failure because I
was competing against other people I was
competing for the wrong things I was
judging my life by the wrong standards
and it wasn't until I hit rock bottom
and had to come to terms with the fact
that I by those definitions had to
define myself as a failure
and that's the amazing thing the minute
I defined my value based on why I all of
a sudden wasn't a failure now I'm just a
guy on an adventure and the standards
are very different and even now
depending what metrics I choose I could
give you a list of metrics right now
that I'll show you that I'm a failure
but I can also show you the adventure
that I'm on that make me feel like I'm I
feel successful every day it really is
about point of view and narrative I can
show you a great a little example of
what narrative means what point of view
really means I was working out the other
day with a friend of mine she was on
FaceTime we were just working out
together and we got halfway through a
very very difficult workout and I said
to her I've got some good news and I've
got some bad news she said what's the
good news I said the good news it she
says what's the bad news I said the bad
news is we're only halfway done she says
well what's the good news I said well
the good news is we're already halfway
my point is it's just point of view one
of them is demoralizing one of them is
exciting and all I did was change my
perspective for the exact same situation
and that's what why did for me and my
personal life it changed my perspective
I went from competing against to
advancing something and the amazing
thing was when I changed that
perspective it is miraculous how quickly
things changed in my life I first
articulated the concept of the golden
circle and why in January of 2006 yes
January 2006 within less than one year
less than one year things were going so
crazy and so strange in less than one
year I was standing at the Pentagon
presenting to the chief of staff and the
Secretary of the Air Force I had had no
previous military connections before
never done any work with the military
before but that's how quickly things
moved in my career when I started
talking about why I do what I do and I
stopped talking about what I do I was
the same idiot I had the same
dysfunction I still didn't know how to
build the structure of a company it's
because when I talked about what I
believed people said there's someone I
need you to meet and things kept moving
quickly I kept having champions but if I
showed up to sell something because I
was special and bla bla bla no one would
have made any introductions for me
whatsoever
because it was about me and this was the
best lesson I learned about starting
with why is that it's never about us
starting with why is always about
someone else if you go through the
process of starting with why if you've
gone through our jump start your why
program a class you'll know that center
to a wise statement it's always for
others it can never be grounded in us in
our benefit and it can never be grounded
in a product or a service it's always a
giving and so this is the fact when you
when you start with a foundation of why
you're always in this giving mentality I
such a short little chapter but it's
such a nice little chapter that just
underscores the value of of where we
come from and remembering where we come
from as a quick aside I'll tell you one
final thing talking about the importance
of origin a current member the exact
study but I remember reading a study
about children who have a sin
of where they come from where what their
grandparents did any sense of family
tree that as simple as knowing as just
where your grandparents come from those
kids are actually more passionate in
their lives on what they do because they
feel like they have a legacy to advance
on a legacy to protect so teaching our
children where they come from as far
back in our family histories as we know
is again it's an origin story it gives
confidence to a young a young person to
know where we come from and that we're
part of a lineage we're part of a legacy
that our lives do not exist solo there
is we don't live in a vacuum that we are
carrying forwards that which came before
us and it is our responsibility to pass
it on to those who come after us and
this is the magic of why what a lovely
way to end the book club on that sort of
discussion
I just realized also I forgot to say
hello to all the wonderful people came
in from all the wonderful countries and
some of my favorite book clubs so if I
may just one indulgence just a quick
couple of shoutouts before we do some
questions to the women of why book club
good to see you the Grandmaster DS and
the transform exhale our book club there
has to be an acronym for that welcome
welcome
the career professionals of Canada book
club hello the Pauline Belgian book club
good to see you
very Flemish of you to be here the
Dakota potato potato peel and pie
Liberty Society literary society once
again good to see you always showing up
always consistent nice to see you again
Bridge House book club from Berlin and
Hamburg little cross city book club I
love that the the rush no more from
South Dakota an afternoon from why group
guys and gals nice to see you also lots
of countries represented as well I saw
as we were logging on Belgium and
Lebanon and Iran and bosnia-herzegovina
and just wonderful lots of Germans here
today as well nice to see everyone okay
let's do some questions if you have any
questions throw them up I'm looking over
here I have the YouTube live over here
so I can read some live questions we'll
start with one of the ones that you
submitted
where are my questions here they are
Lauren from the from the compass within
book club
I like the name of your book club what
did you feel when you first discovered
your why there is a it's the opposite of
what you would expect you would expect
this amazing sort of excitement but my
experience was the opposite was this
incredible calm
I remember this quiet confidence that
that I that I learned this calm that
came over me that things suddenly made
sense that when I looked back in my life
at all the things that had gone well I
realized why they went well it's because
the Y was present and the things that
where I struggled and I didn't know
especially I didn't know why I was
struggling it's because the Y was
missing and all of a sudden things made
sense and Elizabeth Gilbert did a
wonderful TED talk where she talked
about the concept of genius and she
talked about pre-renaissance that a
genius was a daemon a spirit that lived
in the walls and if you did something
remarkable people would say you had your
genius ah
Simon you had your genius with you so
you could never take full credit for the
things that you did well because you had
this genius to support you but if things
failed if things went badly
people would say ah such bad luck you
didn't have your genius with you and so
you didn't have to beat yourself up
either because it was always a
partnership with you and the spirit that
lived in the walls and sometime during
the Renaissance having your genius
become became being a genius and now we
hold people to these ridiculous
standards that they are a genius that
work you are a genius that you did that
so now we have unbelievable pressure on
ourselves that if we had one success
once now we have to live up to that
success all the time and if we fail or
falter we are no longer the genius that
we thought we were that or that people
told us that we were this is what I love
about Y which is it's like that
genius living in the walls again which
is I had my Y with me it was clear with
me as I was doing this or if something
went wrong it's because I didn't have my
Y I should have had my Y front and
center and that's where the calm came
from which is I no longer felt totally
responsible for my own successes or my
own failures
when I was writing my second book
leaders ate last people kept coming up
to me and saying aren't you worried it
won't be as good as the first one aren't
you worried it won't be as successful as
the first one if you do a second TED
talk aren't you worried that it won't be
as successful as the first one in the
other was no of course not
the successes start with why I was a
complete accident I didn't plan any of
it all I did was start with why and then
something happened and watched it was
just a passenger and so for me to plan
to be more successful with something
that I didn't plan in the first place
that's like trying to win the lottery a
second time and then beating yourself up
because you didn't and so I had no
pressure at writing the second book I
didn't have a sophomore slump because I
wasn't comparing that was a very long
answer for a very simple question thank
you from the compass book club okay from
Switzerland the the lesser book club
that's one s not two you say that why is
an origin story and that you need to
discover it not invent it my question
then is how can kids and teenagers find
their why since they're still developing
such a good question in my experience
with the people that I've talked to
I don't believe someone's why is fully
formed until their mid to late teens so
I don't think a ten-year-old that there
Y is fully formed yet remember we are
products of our upbringing and and and
the things that happen to us in our
lives will affect who we become so why
is not fully formed until I think our
early to mid teens the youngest person
that I've done a why discovery what
successfully was was 16
it might go earlier than that that's
just the youngest that I've done but so
good question that is why it is so
important for us to teach our kids
values there's some research that I
stumbled upon when I was writing leaders
eat last that despite all parents good
intentions we don't actually get all of
our values or who we are just from our
parents we get them from all kinds of
things that happen in our
there's only two things that all human
beings everywhere in the world always
get from their parents according to
these researchers one how you treat
yourself and two how you treat others
that comes from our parents okay let's
take a live question should we what is
the painting behind you
[Laughter]
that's the painting behind me it's by a
wonderful Danish artist named Liesl AK
Nielsen I'm a big fan of her work so
there it is okay another question oh
look at this the very next question on
my list from Denmark that's a little
weird that's a little weird didn't see
that happening didn't see that coming
okay question from Denmark Lee select
Nielsen it's not a question from her
it's from ms dort image I don't know how
to say I don't speak Danish so I
apologize is it completely impossible to
discover your why on your own you know
is it completely impossible I'm not
comfortable saying it's completely
impossible but I think it's really
really really difficult because it's
very hard to be objective about
ourselves it's why having outside
feedback at work is really important we
have blind spots sometimes we don't know
very often we don't know how we come
across we don't know sometimes when
we're being rude by accident we don't
know that people find us inspiring when
we didn't know we were that's why it's
hard to do your why it's very hard to
see the patterns in your own life you
know I'm uncomfortable with the word
impossible but I think it's pretty damn
near impossible some people try and I
wish them the best of luck I you can
probably get in the ballpark maybe maybe
but it really requires the help of some
objective outside observer that's why
the other reason we actually often
recommend that the person you choose to
partner with you for to help you find
your why is not your spouse not your
siblings and not your parents because
those relationships are so close that
they too sometimes lack objectivity they
want to tell you the answer so yeah I
think you need you need you need to do
with someone else
yeah hello Charlotte rig yes the
question was it seems that companies
that find their why follow their why and
play the infinite game are always
successful and make a lot of money can
you follow you why not be successful I
think that success requires multiple
things remember the golden circle is
three pieces and I don't believe for a
second that the Y is more important than
the other two pieces it's as important
it's equally as important the problem is
is that in most organizations they're
they're running an organization with two
out of three pieces of an important
essential puzzle in other words most
organizations are run with how and what
but if you only have why you're also
that's not a recipe for success you need
to have the systems and processes you
need to have the values and you need to
ultimately have the product and
marketing and culture that reflect the Y
also so it is one essential piece of the
puzzle
but if you have all those pieces in
place then the likelihood for success
goes up dramatically and even when we
have sudden change like kovat like the
internet that challenges our business
model organizations that start with y
that have good processing systems and
adhere to a code of values and make sure
that everything that they do reflects
their cause more likely will succeed and
pivot through the through the change
just because there has been change in
the world doesn't mean that the end is
nigh we've gone through this in our own
organization where most of our income
came from live events we're not doing
live events anymore but we know that
what we have is important and valuable
in the question we asked ourselves is
how can we ensure and bring our Y to
life in these times and so like a lot of
organizations we were looking at we
looked to online learning
however because human relationships and
human interaction is so important to us
we made a decision a strategic decision
that we wanted to do live class
that's why all of our classes that on
our website are all live you actually
have to show up on time like a classroom
because it's a live class with real
people that was really important to us
so as we pivoted our business we went
back to our why to help inform the kind
of way we wanted to do it so yes you're
more likely to have commercial success
when you start with why and all the
pieces are in balance
here's one from Lawrence seiji Abbott
question is our why simpler than we make
it if our Y is about others by helping
inspiring them making life easier
increasing empathy for a certain cohort
we're educating or providing insight I
think I understand why is should be
relatively simple as a statement the way
we like to write them is to blank so
that blank my Y is to inspire people to
do the things that inspire them so that
together each of us can change our world
for the better
it's a contribution and an impact and
most introspective people can very
easily come up with the impact part I
want to have some sort of impact in the
world specific is better change the
world to broad what's specific and the
impact you want to have in the world but
it's the contribution that's really the
defining part that's the part that's
really the missing part the verb that we
live by the verb that we love so much
that we would tattoo it in our arms you
know that if they build a statue it to
us one day after we're gone they will
say this word of us he inspired you know
so so it has to be something simple you
see this mistake made in companies all
the time you read what they say is their
wise statement and it's like a paragraph
long it's got everything in there it's
got a statement of what their product is
and that has high quality and value for
our customers and yes those things are
important don't get me wrong but it's
it's it's not all has to go in the white
statement it's like the cover of a book
like I don't have to write everything
that's in the book on the cover that's
what the book is for
the only point of the cover the title is
to make you go hmm and want to learn
more and then you read the jacket in the
jacket is the only purpose of the jacket
copy is to make you hmm and you open it
and you read the first page like hmm and
then you buy it that's how it works the
why is the same way it's not a wise
statement isn't supposed to do all the
work it's supposed to do its portion of
the work to set the foundation of
purpose cause and belief then the how
and the what do their role as well I
think I hope that is the question good
question Raj the question was how do
organizations establish their why in
these Co good times and will they have
to change it when we come out of these
Kovach times yeah the answer is no no no
no no your Y will be the same regardless
of the political cultural or
technological world in which we live the
world has changed since Apple was
founded the Y has not changed the world
has changed since Southwest Airlines was
founded the world has changed since the
United States was founded but the Y
remains consistent it remains the same
the opportunity is how to bring it to
life when the times change so your Y now
Raj and your company's Y will be exactly
the same
before Kove it during kovat and after
kovat what will change is how you bring
it to life and what you do that
necessarily has to change but your I
will remain a solid foundation that's
why it's so important and I'll tell you
as we've been going through our
challenges we've had to reinvent
everything we've had to change our
product we've had to change our website
we've had to change the way we talk out
loud to the world we have to change our
marketing inside our company peoples had
to change their entire jobs somebody
thought that this was their job then
because of kovat they now have a
completely new job there's only one
thing that has remained absolutely
eMobile which is our why it's it's what
again it goes back to how it affected me
personally it's that quiet calm that
quiet confidence because in a world of
crazy change where we want to be able to
hang on to something have stability the
why presents is that stable thing again
like the foundation of the house which
is the house can rock damage can be
caused by a hurricane the roof can blow
off in fact you can even lose the whole
house the foundations will always remain
when we go digging for Roman ruins we
always find the foundations everything
else is gone it's the one permanent
thing that is fixed and immobile that is
why we can keep referring to it because
it is there to help us okay Peggy page
turners hello good to see you hello from
the air force in Alabama how can what
basis in Alabama do I remember that's
the big training base out there isn't it
that lack was that Lackland anyway how
can you help yourself or someone else
open their eyes if running full speed
ahead
with them closed due to lack of focus
and direction too much what and not
enough why yes mmm this is hard when you
are starting with why and someone else
in system starting with what in the
business world will say you start with
why and all they care about is starting
with a metric if they're if they believe
everything has to be metric driven
metric is important we just want them in
the right order we want them to come at
the what level not at the Y level so the
question is what do you do we can't
change other people no number of
anonymously sent books will ever change
the minds of our leaders or our friends
we can sometimes have conversations but
even that doesn't work the only thing we
can do is be the leaders we wish we had
we can't change them we can only change
ourselves and so number one start with
empathy we don't know why they are stuck
in what and why they insist on keeping
their eyes closed
maybe it's fear maybe it's because they
never learned anything differently maybe
that's because that the education they
got moving up through their careers and
so that's all they know
and maybe they're struggling maybe
they're insecure so let us not default
to their they don't know what they're
doing so number one is lead with empathy
and you'll find opportunities if you
lead with empathy to walk into someone's
office and be like hey you seemed off
your game today are you okay
I'm worried about you in other words go
to your why be be be focused on why you
do what you do and and you lead from why
and what'll end up happening is you'll
lead your group around you it doesn't
necessarily mean that the stress coming
down from on high isn't difficult but
protect your own people you know person
to the left person to the right and
sometimes whatever pressure we feel from
a what focused leader is temporary
everybody in the airforce knows that you
know one of the worst things about
having the 18-month or two-year rotation
cycles is that if you have a great
leader you lose them really quickly but
everybody also knows that if you have a
bad one they leave in eighteen months to
two years it's kind of like that which
is focus on the things that you can
control worry about the things that yeah
well I just said okay let's see what
else we have here
rishabha thank you for joining when you
want to bring your vision to life do you
have to make a choice between advancing
that vision and making money still gotta
eat right you don't have to so there are
two currencies in the game in the game
of business in the infinite game of
business which is will and resources
they are both essential there's no point
having a vision if you don't have the
the finances to advance it and there's
no point having money if it's just for
money's sake um you need both but there
has to be a bias and the bias has to be
towards towards the vision this goes
back to the celery test right you can do
things just really if you remember from
previous chapters we talked about the
celery test you can do things for the
money but if it puts you out of balance
and you're eating chocolate cake then
just keep in mind that it's a short-term
thing I know that when I discovered my
why
and I became obsessed with the law of
diffusion of innovations I had some very
difficult decisions to make I was living
paycheck to paycheck it didn't have much
money at all
I was just scraping through and I was
this young independent practitioner I
was a solopreneur and people would call
me and say I'd like to hire you and I
always evaluate them through the lens of
why and this is when I couldn't rub two
pennies together and even back then I
would turn down business because it was
more important for me to do business
with people who believed what I believe
because I trusted that those
relationships would not only be
longer-lasting but that those clients
would be more fun to work with that I
would learn more about the why and more
more important to my business that the
likelihood that they would introduce me
to somebody was very very high and that
they would introduce me to a
well-qualified lead because we share the
same values now was it a perfect system
of course not there were times where I
grudgingly took jobs just for the money
because I needed to pay bills but I went
in without wise will eyes wide open I
had no illusions that this was going to
be a long-term relationship I have no
illusions that I was gonna have fun and
I had no illusions that they were gonna
recommend me to other people it was just
what I needed and in short order you
learned that all the time that you
invest in these people that really don't
connect with that sometimes it's not
worth the money that sometimes it was
worth waiting it out to find somebody
that I connected with it's one of the
reasons I became very very conservative
in how I run my business I've always
liked to save money in case that come
across a string of people that I don't
want to work without I can say no so if
ever since the beginning I've been
really good at saving in the business to
give me the freedom to say no in fact as
a quick aside in our business we don't
actually talk about profit because
profit to me is a hollow concept we talk
about freedom we work for freedom the
freedom to give it away their freedom to
take care of our people the freedom to
reinvest in ourselves and the freedom to
say no when we come across a client that
doesn't share our values so instead of
calling it money call it freedom and
work for freedom okay what else we have
here God is a lot of questions
the midlife crisis book club the midlife
crisis book club oh my goodness okay
should we give up our good-paying jobs
from the midlife crisis book club
should we give us our good-paying jobs
in order to pursue a more wife focused
job keep in mind we've been working for
these companies for 25 years the answer
is of course not there are many ways to
bring your Y to life and finding a job
where you connect with your Y where the
companies Y and your Y it connect is not
the only way first of all very often if
you've been working for a company that
long very often you did connect with the
Y and over the years and leadership
changes the new leadership has abandoned
the Y to focus on to be more metrics
focused and so you often hear folks in
your position saying oh remember the
good old days when you had no money in
the what was more difficult and and you
had no no rank whatsoever and you
actually crave going back to those old
times even though you're making more
money than you've ever made you've got
authority that you never thought you
would have and yet you crave those old
times it's because you create connection
with the Y but sometimes having those
people stick around the company is some
of the best bet to get the Y back we've
seen these transitions happen we saw it
happen at Microsoft it went got lost for
a while but a lot of the old timers
stuck around and saw it come back and
proud to say come back you can also live
your Y in smaller context as we just
said in the previous with the previous
question you can you can lead with Y
with your own team you can start still
find great fulfillment and leading with
Y just from a smaller group you'll have
frustration with the company for sure
you know and ultimately the question is
now you're probably more senior in the
organization can you help the company go
back to Y can you help the company go
back to its own roots and re instill
that passion not only in in
in the veterans but to rien spire and
reinvigorate the new people who are
coming into the organization so well you
know if you really care about the
organization you cared about the
fundamental wire from the beginning you
can make it your mission to bring it
back quitting is always an option I know
plenty of senior executives who called
me up excitedly say Simon I quit my
high-paying job to go with my why I know
okay
they seem to be happy they all find
happiness but but it's not the only way
absolutely not let's see what else we
have here
yes Barbour kale high five
[Music]
Barbour kale thank you so much Barbossa
cailli is a groupie she's attended
everything apparently she's read
everything apparently she's gone on our
website and tried everything apparently
and it's changed her life and I Barbara
it's it's shot us like those that
inspire me to keep doing what we're
doing and it inspired we when we do
huddle we do huddle every Monday with
the whole team it's not a business
conversation we check in with each other
we see how we're all doing we report on
what's on our heart and mind hearts and
minds and every huddle we ask an open
question does anybody have a story that
proves why we do what we do that it that
gives reason why we continue to do why
we do what we do and so it's stories
like yours that get read or shared in
our huddle because it inspires the whole
team to keep to keep working hard and
keep this thing alive because we know
that it impacts the lives of others
Thank You barb it's so nice of you to
share thank you for the shout out let's
do another question shall we
bum-bum-bum the freedom to say no yes
Fareed oh here we go from Dylan Smith
Simon what is the most meaningful
question that you have ever been asked
in your life well I would have to say
the most meaningful question I've ever
been asked in my life is probably the
most meaningful question every child
every day of their lives which is why
that's kind of you you gave me that one
doing yeah I think the question why is a
question that I like being asked I like
I like being I like my I like testing my
mettle
I like having an opinion I have a lot of
them and I like when somebody says will
explain to me where that opinion comes
from I like being able to challenge
myself and see do I get caught in a
circular logic that I realized it's not
my opinion I've read it somewhere I've
heard it somewhere I'd like to know
where things come from and every single
one of my books came from asking
question why I wanted to discover
passion where passion comes from why are
some people passionate and some people
aren't you know how do I get my passion
back why are where what the question of
where your passion comes from that's the
question that's start with why leaders
eat last it's the same question like
somebody said okay we know Trust is
important but I want to know what trust
was and I kept asking why does that work
why does that work why does that work
and before you know it I'm in biology
and anthropology I'm not satisfied with
just accepting that things are the way
they are I want to know why they are the
way they are I want to know why things
work and so when I get asked that
question it's the best question because
it means that it means I'm being tested
and I really like that bridge house book
club in Germany guten tag
ah how can I help my company find its
origin why not some marketing why well I
mean you got to go through the right
process right like anything you're
absolutely right so many companies use
our language they use this language of
why when really it's just marketing
and we can tell the difference
to be the best provider of the highest
quality with the greatest value is our
why to be the number one provider to be
the biggest we all know that it's
nonsense you know they have to go
through the right process unfortunately
there's a lot of marketing firms who are
selling why discovery purpose discovery
whatever they call them find your DNA
they all have their own term for the
same thing things with the hope of
producing more work I hate to say it I
used to be in the business and very
often those are six-month engagements
and there are a lot of money and the
reality is to really find your why even
for a large company it just takes a few
hours you can do it in a day we've done
it with the biggest organizations and we
can do it in a day and and so I guess I
guess that's part of it
for the peat the practitioners helping
organizations find their why there's the
wrong process if you go through the
right process of discovering your why
you get your real origin story why
because it's about looking backwards
it's not about looking forwards it's not
about showing up at the company off-site
and putting you know magazine cutouts on
the wall of who we want to be why is not
aspirational aspirations or aspirations
they have their value but that's not to
be confused with why why always comes
from the past it is always an origin
story it always is backwards and when
and and if a why is fuzzy where the
founder is gone another way you can find
your why inside an organization is to
find the zealots
the people who truly believe at every
level at every job function and you find
the common pattern of what they find of
what they you find the pattern of
of the things that they value inside the
organization and when you find the
zealots on an organization and you find
that you can find those patterns of
behavior it's kind of amazing it lives
in the people it's kind of magical so
you have to go through the right process
to get the right result there was a
question that I saw a minute ago that I
really like where did I did I lose it
here clay Granard asked so where can I
find the origin to be able to find my
why in my taxi business other than what
I think it is well your your why has
nothing to do with taxis we know that
for my for a fact many of our careers
are an accident I was dating a girl when
I was when I decided to drop out of law
school I happen to be dating somebody
Rebecca who was studying advertising at
Syracuse and so she was the first person
to put into my head that I should look
into advertising so I had a whole career
in marketing not because that's what I
studied in school it's because my
girlfriend at the time was in
advertising today I've got a whole
career in advertising I mean we fall
into things and so you're why has
nothing to do with taxis unless you
specifically like went to it for a
specific reason other than the economics
the why is how you how you build a
company it's the culture around the taxi
company and you don't have to have a
glamorous product to have a to have a
strong to have a strong culture I've
written about barry-wehmiller you know
it's not a glamorous company their
manufacturing company but there is
strong sense of why and if you ask Bob
Chapman
why did your company exist he says we
build great people to do extraordinary
things
in other words it's how they how they
lead the business how he leads the
business that you can see the why alive
it's not necessarily the physical
product it might be in the way they
deliver the product the way they build a
product the quality control the
advertising the marketing all the stuff
but it's definitely not the product
itself what else do we have
let's do one from Libya and Neal I
assume that it's an ax book club book
club of the two of you I like that if
you were to build a library of Y
statements as a starting as starting
points what would be the one two three
wise you've encountered it in your
career you know there is obviously
overlap and wise and some of the same
words obviously come up but sometimes
writing a wise statement is actually
really frustrating because sometimes the
language that you're writing it in
doesn't provide the right word like the
right word doesn't exist or the right
word has been so overused that it just
loses its power so for example the word
empower the word empower in business is
so hackneyed so overused that if the
word empower is truly in your why it's
such a disappointment because it's just
hard to inspire others with that because
we've heard it so many times so
sometimes the language we speak gets in
the way and so I don't have a library of
the top two or three they're they're
pretty unique yes there's overlap it's
like just like human beings we have
similarities in our personalities but
we're all pretty different
a wise statement is the same it's that
unique wonderful combination of the
contribution and the impact and the
house and what we do that make us who we
are
so don't even know don't even know yes
I've heard lots of the same statements
but for me the fun is not is not the
statement per se but you can tell who
are the why folks and who are the how
folks not always but but you get clues
in there why statements how people tend
to have more building words in in there
why statements okay the road ahead book
club good to see you again you've been
here before I think Netflix has
disrupted the TV and movie industries
how would you articulate Netflix is why
and how they used it to achieve what
they have achieved you know that's a
it's a good question I
what is Netflix is why I should probably
go learn that so whoever
put that question there thanks for that
one I don't know the answer you know
I'll do I'll go look it up I generally
don't comment on newer companies not
because they don't have a why they
absolutely do but I'm always fascinated
if they'll like if they'll be able to
keep it beyond their founders and so I
like companies to have a little a little
bit of a I want them to have a couple of
hard times and to see if they stay true
to their why before actually render
opinion on if I think a company is a
good company or a great company so I
think Netflix is a very interesting
company I think the disruption of the
market has been fascinating I'm but
whether they're a great company I would
wait to I would reserve to see how long
it can last and to see how if they can
weather storm with their why but what
the specific why is I'll have to get
back to you okay why in a mental health
point of view okay the wine a mental end
point of view bipolarity massive mood
fluctuations and you lose the why and
you change your mind ending up in the
vicious cycle yes there's no question
that if somebody is struggling with
mental health it absolutely will affect
many things in their lives including
their why the way we articulate a wise
statement a why is who you are when
you're operating at your natural best
and if there's something interrupting
that natural best like mental health
challenges then of course it has the
possibility to disrupt one's why okay
what else do we have
[Music]
hello Jake from the Netherlands the
nater LUNs
[Music]
looking forward to seeing you too Jake
at the 22-21 mindset tour yes what is
the what does they say the question
again what is the essential way that a
leader must explain to their team
members so why is a foundation sometimes
they're pretty and can be articulated to
the outside world and sometimes like a
foundation of the house they're kind of
just kind of ugly looking but really
necessary and they're really really
inspiring to the person who's why it is
but sometimes they're a little bit
chunky and clunky for the outside world
and so you want the Y to inspire and be
the foundation of how you present it to
the outside world so it has to reflect
the Y it doesn't it doesn't always have
to be the literal words of the Y so for
example I don't always talk about
inspiring people to do the things that
inspiring them but you'll see themes and
all of my work sometimes I use the word
inspire a lot better use the word
optimism I use the word forward and you
see that the idea of inspiring people to
do what inspires them you'll see that I
often talk about togetherness I talk
about human connection you can see the Y
is the foundation of how I'm presenting
things and so if you listen to enough of
the stuff that I say or you read enough
of the stuff that I write you'll start
to see a pattern even though the words
stories and ideas may be different
there's a pattern is a pattern of
optimism there's a pattern of human
connection there's a pattern of
togetherness in other words you can see
my wise alive and well because I work
very hard to make sure that it shows up
everywhere we do it even in the titling
of my books I go to to blows with my
publisher because they want to put my
name big at the top of the book and I
refuse I've always wanted my name really
small down the side they won't let me do
that I lose that fight but but if you
notice I refuse to put my name at the
top of the book because to me it's not
it's it's if I start with why to inspire
people to do what inspires them it's
always about others
it's always about others so in if if I'm
just the guy that wrote the book I have
to start with the idea
the title always has to come first and I
always insist that my name comes second
my point is is the Y influences how I
show up they the Y influences how I
speak and you'll see this in our great
leaders you'll find patterns on how they
speak that sometimes is literally their
why but it's definitely the foundation
Daniel Ackerman yes great question so
Daniel works for a fire department
decided to try and find the Y for his
crew and they succeeded in finding the Y
for each of the individuals but they
struggle to find a wife or for the
station for the whole group there's no
senior leader per se handing something
on down the origin story of fire
departments probably not very helpful
here and so as Daniel as you know each
place you've worked as a different
culture and this and not all stations
are created equal you have worked in
stations before where you felt like you
belonged and it felt great and the
culture is strong and you've been in
other stations where it either had a
dysfunctional culture and nobody got
along or there was a strong culture but
you didn't feel like you belong so it's
that pattern of the zealots it goes back
to what I said before which is you an
organizational y is finding the pattern
of connection for those who feel like
they belong not everyone in that station
belongs but but there's probably a
critical mass that really do and so what
you'll find is if you take all the
people who love it here I love it here
this is the best place I've ever worked
you you guys the best guys I've ever
worked with right you'll find a pattern
exists in all of them so here's an
exercise that I do that has been very
very helpful
it's called left list right list it's
better to do it if you have somebody to
help take
through this process objective outsider
as we talked about before but it's very
helpful have everybody take a piece of
paper fold it in half left list write
list there's a list on the Left list on
the right number the side on the left
one through five number the side on the
right one through five ask everybody on
the left to right the just a list of
names of the people that you have worked
with that you absolutely love working
with them they get it that you want to
be more like them and it doesn't have to
actually be five it could be two three
it could be seven it doesn't matter it's
just an exercise right so on the Left
list you put all of the people who you
want to be more like or who you admire
right on the right list you put all the
people who just don't get it and they
don't have to necessarily be in this
station but the ones who and again you
have to do this exercise with the
zealots right because we're looking for
patterns of connection and who you are
at your natural best so on the right
list you put the people who just don't
get it that when you see their name come
up on the caller ID you're like what now
right the ones who everything is
excruciating right and there they may be
good people it's just you just struggle
it's like oil and water you just
struggle to connect right and then what
you do next is you take all the people
on the left list and you and you have
everybody write a list of human
characteristics that define everybody on
the left list so if they write down a
word they're wonderful dynamic people
that have wonderful characteristics
about them but every word they write
down has to define every person on the
left list and by the way we ignore the
right list it's it's just a foil that
each one of those words may define one
or two of those people on the right list
at best every word they write down in
the list of characteristics has to find
everybody in the left list then you get
together in smaller groups you compare
your list you compare you people and you
find the overlaps on all of those words
and you will let the down you Whittle it
down so what you're finally left with is
a group of words human characteristics
that define every single person on every
single person's list it's an amazing
experience and what you'll find is that
one of those were
seems to feel bigger than the others the
other ones are more functional the more
how types and one of those words tends
to be a little bit bigger that is your
why that is how you do an organizational
wise how I like to do an organizational
why there are multiple ways to do it
that's how I like to do it's called left
/ right listen oh we did that actually
of course I could have given you a much
simpler answer Daniel which is in the
book find your why sorry I forgot in the
book find your why it's broken up into
two sections which is how to find the
wife for yourself but we also put it in
there how to find your wife or your
organization I strongly recommend pick
up a copy of find your why you only need
one copy for the whole group and it'll
take you through how to find your wife
or your your station sorry about the
long answer let's get another live
question what do you have how will I
update chapter 13 now that I've had
fourteen year thirteen years how long
has this been going to long fourteen
years of experience doing this why stuff
this leadership stuff you know I wasn't
planning on doing that but maybe I
probably should talk about my journey I
really hate talking about myself in
these things to be honest with you but
but there's probably some good lessons
that I should impart about the things
that I got right in the things that I
got wrong on this why journey and the
risks that I took that were worth it and
the risks that I took that weren't worth
it I've definitely learned a lot of
lessons so yeah yeah I'll do that I'll
add that to the end thank you but it's
definitely going at the end of not the
beginning unfortunately as a statistic
in publishing that we know that most
people don't finish books which was kind
of disappointing because I had some
really good stuff at the end here with
Ben Coleman
some of the origin stories I'd like the
second half of this book
maybe I got better at writing was I got
as I was doing it
let's see somebody wrote here from the
okay hold on give me a second here the
less dem Manette book club
Rafael Sasha Lou Salome and Rafaela once
you've found your why what's next well
of course it's like commencement from
when you graduate college
we call it commencement because it's
just the beginning I call the book start
with why because it's just the start
once you have your why then the next big
question is what do I do with it well if
you run a business you want to start
auditing things which is let's look at
our marketing let's look at our sales
let's look at our hiring practices look
like our incentive products incentive
practices let's look at our physical
product line and see is our y showing
through and everything you want to do an
audit make sure that your Y is present
everywhere a great example of this was
Disney under the later years of Michael
Eisner Michael Eisner unfortunately he
lost his partner in Frank Wells who died
in an accident and that beautiful
balance of why and how whence completely
sideways and unfortunately Mike Eisner
lost sight of the why and he became
obsessed that very often happens when we
lose sight of the why he became obsessed
with world domination he became obsessed
with being number one and being the best
and he'd forgotten that the journey and
they invested in many many many
businesses that did very well some of
them did well something too terribly
actually when Bob I when when he left
Bob Iger and Tom Staggs took over they
evaluated the entire portfolio and they
looked at the businesses that no longer
reflect the why so for example they were
selling they were in the movie business
making r-rated movies did you know that
a Disney Company produced and made
Reservoir Dogs like what does a company
obsessed with good clean family fun
making things like Reservoir Dogs they
had a music label that produced a band
called world war three doesn't sound
very Disney and so even though some of
those businesses were
profitable they completely divested of
them and if you've noticed Disney has
never and will never go into gaming they
don't own casinos they would if they
owned a casino on the Vegas trip it
would be the best casino ever they would
have Star Wars and Marvel it would be
incredible but they won't because it
violates their values and so you want to
keep everything aligned now if it's an
individual it's the same thing one of
the things that I did when I learned my
why is I looked at that thing close to
me I actually looked at some of my
friends and I realized that I was
actually maintaining some friendships
that I actually derived no joy from
being in those friendships they were
more they were more work than they were
worth and that I realized that if I
didn't call them they would never call
me if I didn't make a plan with them
they would never make a plan with me so
I sent them a lovely polite email saying
I want to do things that bring me joy
and though I still care about you I
realize this is lopsided I'll always be
here if you want to reach out one did
and amazingly a few didn't in other
words I actually went and looked at you
know some of the the company I was
keeping I made decisions in what clients
I did business with and I also made sure
that how I showed up and it's just it's
it's work to this day fourteen years on
it still work I still catch myself
getting emotional or reacting to things
but showing up with my wife front and
center in meetings or with colleagues
that I wanted to make sure that I was
bringing my to why my why to life at all
times it is a journey it is a game of
constant improvement I have a lot of
work still to do but I'm Way better than
I was 14 years ago because I keep it
front and center and I think I talked
about this in one of the previous calls
I surround myself with symbols the color
orange you know we do things we we have
a sense of humor you know the inspired
t-shirts that that we have on our
website for example we didn't produce
those t-shirts for other people the
first inspire t-shirt I just went on one
of those websites that you can make a
t-shirt for yourself and I made a bunch
of them teachers for myself
they were great t-shirts with orange
letters really small right here in the
chest that said inspire and I made and I
bought four of them for myself and and
so almost everything that we do the
t-shirts that we sell to others those
t-shirts were the t-shirts that I have
ten years ago I made them for myself and
that's why we offer them to other people
because the whole idea is they work for
me maybe they'll work for other people
so it's about keeping it front and
center and reminding yourself every
single day of why you get out of bed in
the morning I think that's a nice way to
end we have a couple of little surprises
for you because you guys are so
fantastic and so wonderful I'm so
grateful that you've shown up I know I
recognized a lot of names and a lot of
book clubs here that you've come almost
if not every single book club for six
weeks which is really a wonderful
commitment we wanted to do our way of
saying a little thank you and so we
wanted to give you guys all if you want
to go take any of the classes on our
website a 20% discount for everybody
here we're editing this part out of the
thing it's just for it's just for book
club
so the code is why book club so if you
if you put in why book club it'll give
you 20% off any of our any of our
classes so please please come and join
take advantage it's just our way of
saying thank you so much for showing up
here week after week after week we love
you once again if you missed any part of
this want to relive any part of it go we
watch any part of it share with any
friends we will be posting it in its
entirety with one little piece coming up
on youtube so go ahead and check that
out once again remember we started book
club we're not because it was about
reading a book but it was about doing
something together now that you have
your book clubs going I really really
hope that you will keep your book clubs
going we haven't decided yet if we're
going to continue to do this with my
other books but we will definitely do
other special things if we don't do book
club but you know maybe we'll do book
club for some of the other books maybe
but if you do keep your book comes clubs
going and I please please please I wish
you do I'd like to recommend some books
that you could possibly read for your
book club if you're a bunch of
introverts please go read Susan Cain's
quiet it's a wonderful book
everyone should read man's search for
meaning by Viktor Frankl I think that is
mandatory reading for every human being
and definitely every book club we also
like Bernie Browns there dare to lead
check that one out
seth godin x' triads these are these are
these are really important books in the
of the subject so please check those out
start with man's search for meaning it
is the foundation for everything else
and I hope you keep your book clubs
going we will obviously let you know
when if we start another one from our
stuff again as you know we have our live
classes and for those of you who took
jump start your why thank you very much
it was so successful we're continuing to
add more please feel free to go take
jump start your why again and we've
added something called office hours so
for those of you who either went through
the jump start your why workshop or you
didn't but you have a good sense of your
why but you want to work on it some more
and you want some one-on-one coaching
with one of our master trainers please
go sign up for office hours we we don't
we don't we didn't put any limits to the
number people that can sign up and you
can pay what whatever you want you can
pay what if you can for office hours so
please go check out office hours if you
want to get deeper into the details of
your own personal why the only thing we
ask is you show up with some sort of
wise statement whether you got it from
one of our programs or not which is fine
my brilliant wonderful friend Jen
Waldman this is very exciting is
teaching a class called how to pivot if
you are a freelancer or if you are a
small business owner and in these kovat
times you need to pivot your business
Jen is one of the people that I have
called during this this time she has an
amazing story she has a small business
herself and her business was rendered
completely shut during Kovich she own
she owns a studio at acting studio and
obviously she can't do that anymore in
real life and it wasn't easy for her to
simply just do it online and so she
completely changed her business model
and she is she managed to keep every
single person on her team employed in
fact
her business is actually growing because
of her pivot so we asked Jen to take
everything that she did that she learned
and pivoting her business and if she
would share some of it with the likes of
everyone else so please check out Jen's
class and go ahead and use your 20%
coupon to take Jen's class with that I
will say thank you for joining thank you
for being here it's been an absolute joy
reading start with why with you I will
thank you we'll all get a thank you at
the end of the book and the
acknowledgments in the in the new
version
it'll book Ovid book club will we'll be
in there too thank you for helping me
take care of yourself take care of each
other hopefully I'll see you real real
soon thank you everyone